ladies and gentlemen wow Ray apps to be
criminally charged for events on January
6th his attorney says yeah this is a big
one why did it take this long because
he's suing Fox News I think he just
announced that's the next bit of news
but the Revelation was made in a lawsuit
that Epps filed against Fox News on
Wednesday that accused the network and
former host Tucker Carlson of defaming
him so it is because of this lawsuit
that he is I'm sorry it is because of
the lawsuit we know he's been criminally
charged I suppose the argument they're
making is that he's being charged
because of them or something I don't
know dude here's the thing let's see
yeah let's just say okay wow we'll play
Make Believe for a moment we'll say you
know what this is just some guy who went
there he wasn't working with any kind of
federal agency uh and he hasn't been
protected by his status as someone who
worked with them even so even if we want
to say that's the case good this guy
should be charged you're Whispering
you're into the day before telling
people that they have to go into the
capitol everyone starts calling you a
Fed you're still doing it going around
instigating you're whispering in the ear
of the first person to break a barrier
down before they break the barrier down
why did it take so long for this guy to
be arrested all right Absol lawyer
blamed Carlson for the potential
forthcoming charges take a look at it
stop stop thank you Tucker Carlson
it wasn't like yeah yeah no it was
Tucker Carlson's fault Tucker Carlson
was actually whispering in Ray Epps ear
before Ray Epps whispered in everyone
else's ear to start breaking the
barriers down you know what Tucker is
still gonna destroy Fox News even not
being there because if this you know if
he wins if if EPS you know has a case
here against them then uh
OCD about typos no I mean this is very
real um I've spoken about ray ops a bit
in the past we've had some conversations
about him in about January 6th and just
how interesting it is that he was so
clearly involved in instigating and yet
he never got in any trouble uh and so
look him being charged as a win-win
regardless when you look at how many
people were rotting away in prison in
solitary confinement were having their
rights violated for doing things like
entering the building just a a fraction
when you look what happened to Brandon
straka yeah they they claimed he was he
was outside of the Capitol and they
claim that they heard him saying that
people should go in or something along
those lines and there's not even footage
of him saying it they just claim the
voice saying it on camera is him and
then he ended up having to plead down to
avoid prison time and this guy was was
whispering in people's ears telling them
to break barriers down was telling
people on January 5th that they needed
to go into the capital and here it is
July of 2023 and he's now being charged
this is ridiculous two and a half years
later two and a half years later and I
just love that he's saying Carlson is
he's blaming Carlson for the upcoming
charges I just tweeted uh thank you
Tucker Carlson scholarship so is that
why he's announcing that they're gonna
assume you fox for Tucker's voice
because he didn't do anything wrong and
then Tucker Carlson just made him look
bad for no reasons uh yeah this is
really funny look at Rolling Stones said
they said the lawsuit alleges the
network particularly its former host
Tucker Carlson painted apps as an
undercover federal agent in order to
push a conspiracy that the FBI helped
orchestrate the riot in the aftermath of
the events of January 6 FOX News
searched for a scapegoat to blame other
than Donald Trump or the Republican
Party eventually they turned on one of
their own telling a Fantastical story in
which Ray Epps who was a trump supporter
that participated in the Pro of the
protests
was responsible for the mob that broke
into the capital and interfered the
peaceful transition of power The
Conspiracy Theory blah blah blah fat fed
fed do they mention here that they that
he's being criminally charged uh
they said in may they were notified by
the that was the other article said that
in may they were notified Rolling Stones
had it before okay yeah I don't I don't
know if uh
I don't think Rolling Stones bringing up
that he's blaming Carlson for being
criminally charged
how does that work if you're criminally
charged with something and then you try
and Sue the person that that got the yo
look at this look at this I'm sorry but
look it says Epps has not been arrested
for his involvement and Carl's and
others have alleged the justice
department is protecting him because
working for the FBI yet in the lawsuit
Epps says he's being criminally charged
recently informed apps that it plans to
prosecute him yeah Rolling Stone fact
check your garbage unless the daily wire
is wrong I really doubt it well Rolling
Stone has they've really been bound 100
lately huh we saw their article about
that's bad about sound of Freedom did
you see their article it wasn't there's
like a meme like a screenshot side by
side of the article about sound of
freedom and then their article about
cuties that Netflix yes that's right
they said it was like a great yeah I
gotta read this I got to read this
section 94 of the lawsuit finally in May
23 the Department of Justice notified
apps that it would seek to charge him
criminally for the events on January 6
2021 two and a half years later the
Relentless attacks by Fox and Mr Carlson
and the resulting political pressure
likely resulted in the criminal charges
wow Tucker Carlson can I buy you a beer
yeah you can actually is it if we're
supposed to it's like conservative dad's
Ultra right the question is when they
publish these kinds of stories trying to
smear Tucker and apps is the person
we're supposed to be sympathetic to who
do they think he's gonna buy that like
who who in the country is gonna go oh
man because everyone on the right is
gonna say either hey this guy is a Fed
uh or B he's somebody who got away with
it when he shouldn't have when you look
at people riding in prison over far
lesser wrongdoing uh and what the left
is going to say is this guy's an
insurrectionist who do they think this
is appealing to who who's going to shed
tears over this guy yeah right like
Tucker Carlson accused him of inciting
violence at the Capitol and now he's
going to get charged for it and Rolling
Stones defending him that's amazing
that's well that's why you know
something's up what is this that's why
you know something's up with this guy
why would one of the
insurrectionists be defended by Rolling
Stone by basically everyone in the media
everyone in media everyone has
acknowledged him fact Checkers have come
to his defense and said he did nothing
wrong come on yeah they love that guy
he's on here saying stuff I believe is
that correct he's on videos
but they love this guy the guy who is on
camera on January 5th saying we need to
go inside the capitol dude he says that
true crowded people and they start
cheering fed fed fed fed and yeah they
start chanting at and pointing at him so
he was inciting yes he was inciting and
then lo and behold the next day they all
do the thing he said that they should do
the night before right after he whispers
into somebody's ear and that person
breaks down one of the barriers and it
is July of 2023 and we're just getting
word that this guy might be charged and
it's because of Tucker Carlson are you
kidding me what's interesting are you
kidding is it they announced that they
were gonna charge him in May but I
haven't heard out anything about it
until today which is two and a half
months later uh two months later I guess
Tucker is a a National Treasure I I I
deeply respect this man he stopped an
insurrectionist him he brought an
insurrectionist to Justice he provided
evidence
about uh Jake chancelly I believe his
name right now I'm Jacob Chancellor
showing him walking through the halls
with a police escort and them even
trying to open doors for him and he also
exposed right apps as one of people
inciting the violence and and the
tearing down to the barricades telling
people to go inside
that the thing about this whole January
6th thing is you'll find most people
even Donald Trump himself says there
were bad people there they should be
charged but some of them many of them
weren't
I think everybody agrees the violence
the fighting was bad even Trump posted
on January 6 our side believes in law
enforcement the media tried lying about
all of it trying to claim that he was
egging people on to go there for
violence Tucker Carlson exposes the lies
in the manipulations while also
criticizing someone who actually incited
violence that is the balanced honest and
moderate approach to what happened we
don't like the violence on January 6. we
don't like the innocent people being
charged Tucker is effectively calling it
out so effective it seems Epps is
actually finally getting charged for
being a principal actor and inciting the
violence that day this is crazy remember
when when Trump said go over there and
March peacefully he was actually sending
out a top secret right wing doggle so I
don't know if you know this but every uh
conservative in the country every right
winger actually has a chip in our brain
and when right-wing pundits say things
that sound totally innocuous they're
actually telling us to do something evil
so Trump activated that magic power uh
and he said go over there peacefully and
have your voice heard and of course what
he was really saying is you know like
enter the the building and commit acts
of violence uh now Ray apps on the other
hand when he was saying enter the
capital what he was actually dog
whistling was be peaceful no no have
your voice heard it's a song everyone's
getting it back
it's a song about uh computer
programming enter the capital just meant
like press shift and it was misconstrue
he says we gotta enter the cat no you
misunderstood it's a song about computer
programming it was like Rock the Casbah
for computers
you know it's all big misunderstanding
and now he's going to jail he's going to
jail because the Tucker Carlson is fake
news I mean seriously these people hold
on a second does anyone in the media
think that Tucker Carlson has any
influence over who's charged the only
reason he has any say on this or that
he's related to this is because he
showed actual footage of what the guy
was doing to the American people to the
point where the media couldn't ignore it
Tucker Carlson can't just fabricate
charges against the person and then have
that person go
what world are they living in what world
do these people live in where Tucker
Carlson can falsely accuse you of a
crime and you go to jail
a world where they falsely accuse people
of crimes they should know that Tucker
doesn't have that ability wouldn't it be
great if he did though if he had that
kind of power I want Tucker in power I
don't like you and I'm going to have you
sent to prison I'm actually
uh Team Tucker now all I can do is say
actually shame is the one who can
actually do his voice actually
it's about you just interviewed on
Andrew Tate you guys see it I did not
that's okay I I didn't watch the whole
thing you went to Romania is that right
yeah no I mean you have to I guess yeah
I watched a decent amount of it and I
think it's really great for people who
aren't familiar with Andrew Tate but for
anybody who's watching listen Andrew
Tate you're like like it's it's his
thing it's a Spiel it's a short advice
Tucker didn't give too much of himself
in the interview it's mostly just tape
at least I've only seen Clips I only saw
like the first 10 minutes
um but you know regardless of the who it
is that he's interviewing I just love
how many views his videos you know these
these this show of his is getting on
Twitter because I mean every day more
and more you just continuous continue to
see that Legacy Media is irrelevant and
is dying and everybody should celebrate
that dude it's like him in a leather
jacket too can we talk Chillin can we
can we talk about Tucker corporate
corporate media I know I love that new
picture here check out the story out
from Daily Mail msnbc's Micah Brzezinski
blames 80 year old Biden's staff for
making him look old argue his aides
should be making sure he doesn't fall
over and should be controlling his
schedule oh my god dude could you who
watches these people and thinks they're
like smart critical thinkers oh my God
no I think that's actually really
important they're hurting their own
argument like I don't know I mean the
people who follow it are like tell me
they made it where to stand and how high
to jump they said it's a somewhat
Salient Point Mika's saying like you
know we've done stage performances you
don't necessarily know where all the
pitfalls are on the stage when you're
done you hopefully someone's gonna point
to the exit for you otherwise you're
looking around like where's the exit I
just got here and she's saying that the
handlers should like let them know ahead
of time you're going to be walking off
over here there should be people waving
him things like that but at the same
time she's also kind of admitting that
he's 80 and frail like mentally not
stable because like realistically you
look around really quick you're the
president you can do whatever you want
you can laugh and joke with people as
you're looking around you can make a
display of it but the guy's so old and
it looks like even like his musculature
is having a hard time holding his bones
up sometimes thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time